a video game series called middle Gear
Solid it was rumored that there's a
character in the game that's inspired by
snake and as you to do the voice over
well it's like look I you know I'm
pretty lazy by Nature remember there
have been many different times when
people you know wanted to do something I
don't know I'm a movie guy you have to
understand that from my point of view
whether it's Elvis or snake pisin or
Jack Burton or RJ mccre that was that
project that was that thing you get into
that mindset you you create that you
want to make that world happen just like
I used to do interviews when Elvis was
coming out and they would say come on do
a little Elvis for us you know it's like
I it doesn't it doesn't work that way
you don't just slide in and out of Elvis
you you you you go to work on it you
refine it and then you do it and you get
paid for that